Pennywise may not be the scariest thing in
Derry, Maine, after all.
Audiences who have taken in ​It: Chapter
Two​ were a little surprised to see a familiar
face pop up in the film: none other than Stephen
King himself, who appeared as the proprietor
of the store Secondhand Rose.
Screenwriter Gary Dauberman revealed that
he wrote the part of Secondhand Rose's owner
with King in mind, but stopped just short
of actually spelling out his preference in
the screenplay.
He told Inverse:
"I wrote him into the script just along the
lines of 'looks like Stephen King' early on
in the drafts.
You know, just kind of planting the seed."
Dauberman was unsure if King would be willing
to take the time to cameo in the film.
Luckily, while King's high-profile cameo appearances
may have come in the '80s and '90s, he's always
been pretty game to pop up in adaptations
of his material.
It's just that in recent years, he's mostly
stuck to the small screen.
King's very first movie appearance was in
a film not even adapted from one of his novels:
it was in the bizarre 1981 fantasy flick Knightriders,
which was directed by his friend George A.
Romero.
King and Romero would go on to collaborate
on the excellent horror anthology film Creepshow
the following year, and in that film, King
didn't just cameo; he actually starred in
one of its segments, "The Lonesome Death of
Jordy Verrill."
"You get in that water, Jordy, you might as
well sign your death warrant."
"I'm a goner already, Daddy."
Since then, King has turned in cameos in no
fewer than fifteen films and television series.
He cameoed in 1986's Maximum Overdrive, which
is also the only film that King ever directed.
After that, he appeared in 1987's Creepshow
2, 1989's Pet Sematary, and plenty more.
Dauberman related that he was content to just
keep his fingers crossed and hope that King
would agree to the cameo.
However, Andy Muschietti revealed that he
was down to do a little more bargaining in
the interest of making it happen.
The director told Games Radar that:
"We had an increasingly good relationship
with King after he saw the first movie.
He became like a friend, and I wanted him
to participate a little more in this one as
he did not participate [in] the first movie
at all.
I didn't want him to intervene in the creation,
and he's very clear he doesn't want to mess
with the people adapting his work, but I still
wanted to keep him in the loop and get his
thoughts."
The director continued that King actually
offered some thoughts that made it to the
big screen:
"So, I sent him the first draft.
He gave a list of things he would like to
see.
It felt more like a fan, because after reading
it, he was like 'I would like to see Paul
Bunyan'.
So, I was like, 'I'll give you Paul Bunyan.'"
Muschietti is referring, of course, to a flashback
in which the adult Richie remembers being
bullied and forced to flee an arcade in his
younger years.
Young Richie takes refuge in Derry's park,
where a giant, 20-foot tall statue of Paul
Bunyan comes terrifyingly to life, chasing
him with its gigantic axe.
With that bargaining chip in place, Muschietti
says he then sprang his request on King.
"I asked him to do a cameo and he said, 'Well,
you have to know, I'm a jinx.
Every movie I was in bombed.'
He said it with humor, and I said, 'I think
we're going to break the spell, let's do it.'"
We know full well that the Master of Horror
is constantly busy conjuring up his latest
nightmare…
"Do you know me?
It's frightening how many novels of suspense
I've written."
...but we'd love it if he kept those appearances
coming.
Stan Lee is no longer with us, and we can
think of nobody better to claim Stan the Man's
title of King of Cameos.
We'll just have to see if he shows up in Doctor
Sleep, another adaptation of his work, when
it's released in November.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.